I'm gonna break it down we're gonna
bring it all the way the [ __ ] down hey
you're not thank God yeah that's the
Internet this is how to wear a suit like
a real rock and roller
this is Brioni creative director Justin
O'Shea GQ style editor in chief will
Welch I think in the last like 25 years
the rock and roll suit has meant a
skinny fit but also skinny lapels you
know two buttons everything narrow
narrow narrow you've got some real
breaths going on here the one thing
which I'm trying to get across with the
new Briony is that for melody it doesn't
need to be boring you know we're
battleship great right you know where
we're at cognac we're a velvet we're a
color that isn't so normal if you want
to be an individual in the world of the
digital age where everyone wants to be
their own you know like slip it up and
start acting like it
right start dressing like it yeah Callie
mid-city if it's City it's the only way
to get anything done around here let's
talk about this suit because you are
wearing the new silhouette of Brioni
suit that you introduced is that right
this is the Continental it's a one
button food button stance is quite deep
show off the tie a little bit of still
popping out so right now you're kind of
known for this big Tyner for the show
I'd say runs goddamn not because
everyone was like doing these like
little ones and I like what is that
right that's like such a girl's not
right give me the big [ __ ] peak lapels
you're on centimeter 76 centimeters from
from top to bottom with no no vents at
the back no van like to put out the vibe
you know when I'm are at the bar having
the element of mohair gives like a
better structure it's out of luster when
you're walking out you know the Sun
catchy yo I literally will never have a
wear another shirt except the silver
Justin as you were putting your first
collection for Brioni together were you
looking at any rock and rollers for
inspiration you know what were you
looking at for inspiration gangsters are
always they're always dressed impeccably
good just to go around [ __ ] shooting
people
then I thought or what's the step path
that barrels like vampires my favorite
vampire movie is a Bram Stoker's Dracula
yeah hey wack
I think you have signature style and
there are a couple key moves you want to
hear what I think there I'd love to me
what you think might keep me down peak
lapel weight silk shirt weight big
fuck-off wins or not we and then just
some badass shoes what do you call these
shoes a good guide dirty this is the
first new Briony shoe I have to say even
though I didn't make them I felt like
[ __ ] awesome that's it how to wear a
suit like a real rock and roller rooney
creative director Justin O'Shea I'm will
Welch thank you I'm